欸,大家好!
今天我们要来聊一个听起来就超刺激的主题
叫做抢帽子交易
也就是很多人说的scalping
好,我们的目标很简单哦
就是把三种最核心的策略
把它们摊开来
一个一个拆解给你看
然后帮你找到那个
嗯,最对你为的交易风格
OK,我们马上开始
OK,在我们深入策略之前
先来问自己一个问题
在交易的世界里
你觉得自己比较像老鹰
还是蜂鸟
你看
老鹰呢
它会在高空盘旋
很久很久
非常有耐心的等待
就为了那一次出手
捕获一个巨大的猎物
这就很像是我们说的波段交易
那蜂鸟呢
完全不一样
它的翅膀振动频率超级快
很精准的从一朵花
飞到另一朵
每次只吸一点点花蜜
但是
它靠着超高的频率
最后累积起来的成果
是非常惊人的
没错
这个就是我们今天要聊的
抢帽子交易的精神
是的
抢帽子交易的整个核心精神
真的就是这三个字
快
很
准
什么意思
快
就是进出场速度要超级快
绝对不能脱泥带水
很呢
是指停损要够果断
一发现苗头不对
马上走人
不要有任何悬念
准就是
你看准了目标
就要毫不犹豫的出手
所以我们讲了半天
到底什么是scalping
白话文来说
它就是一种
高频率的当冲手法
它的赚钱逻辑
不是去等一个
什么大波段
大行情
不是哦
它是在非常非常
短的时间里
可能就几分钟
甚至是几秒钟而已
从每一次价格
小小的跳动里面
去抠出那么一点点利润
然后靠着大量的次数
达到一个积少成多的效果
OK我们来看看他的几个重点
首先好处是什么
就是效率真的超级高
结果来得很快
这就很适合那种
你知道没办法整天盯盘
但可以在某个时段火力全开高度专注的人但是挑战也来了你想想看时间切得这么细图表上一定会有一大堆杂讯
也就是假讯号
所以啊这就代表一件事
你的风险控管
你的几率要求绝对是顶天的
要非常非常高
好了解了基本概念之后
我们就来看第一个策略模型
趋势确认
你可以把它想象成一个顺势而为的
建筑师
他的核心逻辑非常非常简单
就是一句话
永远只跟着市场的大方向走
就像搭顺风车一样
我们绝对不逆风操作
那这个建筑师是怎么做的呢
他们会用一个双重镜头的概念
来确保自己没看错方向
首先先拿出广角镜
也就是看向30分钟
这种比较大的K棒图
来判断现在整个市场的大浪
是往上还是往下
然后呢再换向显微镜
也就是五分钟图
去找到一个最精准
最漂亮的切入点
这样就能确保我们每一次出手
都是站在市场动能最强的那一边
好我们就来一步一步拆解
这个做多的SOP
第一步先看30分K
OK我们要确认价格
有没有冲破前面的高点
这个专业术语叫结构突破
BOS
好一旦突破
OK趋势向上了
第二步接着去找一个因为价格冲太快留下的一个空白区
我们叫它价格真空区
Fair Value Gap简称FBG
找到之后呢就是等价格回来补这个缺口
好第三步
哎价格已进到这个区间
马上把图切换到五分K
第四步这时候我们就要盯着看
有没有一个假跌破
就是故意往下扫一下单
最后一步
这个讯号一出现
不要犹豫
马上进场
然后停损就设在
刚刚那个假跌破的
最低点下面一点点
你看
整个流程是不是超有系统的
如果你就是那种
喜欢照着SOP
一步一步来的人
那这个策略
哎
简直是为你量身打造的
OK
接下来我们来看第二种策略
这个就更有趣了
我们叫它追逐利润的猎人你可以这样想象市场里面好像有一块看不见的金钱磁铁而猎人的工作就是去预测这块磁铁接下来会把价格吸到哪里去
那什么是流动性磁铁
其实市场的价格在跑
它不是乱走的
它是在寻找燃料
也就是流动性
那燃料在哪里
就在那些挂满了大家停损单
或是准备要突破进场单的地方
这些地方订单超级集中
所以价格就像被磁铁吸过去一样
因为它需要去触发那些单子
才能完成交易
也才能获得往下一步走的动能
所以啊
这个猎人策略的洛基就很有意思了
第一步
我们先在比较大的时间周期上
找出一个目标
比方说一个还没被碰到的前波高点
第二步
好玩的地方来了
我们不是傻傻等它涨上去
反而是要等它先往下蹲一下
去把下面那些单子扫掉
第三步
这个先蹲后跳的讯号已出现
就是我们的进场点
立刻进去做多
那我们的目标呢
当然就是我们一开始就设定好的那个高点
这种策略就特别适合那些
对市场感觉很敏锐
好像总能猜到市场下一步想干嘛的交易者
好了
最后一种策略
我们要反扑归真
回到最原始也最经典的东西
纯粹的价格行为
这个方法呢
我们叫它极简主义者
就是什么复杂的指标
我们通通都不要
我们只看市场结构里面
最基本也最重要的那个元素
它的核心里面只有四个字
角色互换
你想想看哦
一个原本是天花板的压力区
当它被价格很强势的冲过去之后
它会变成什么
没错
它会变成新的地板
也就是支撑
我们要交易的
就是价格回来测试这个新地板
而且确认站稳了的那个瞬间
整个过程非常干净
在一张图上就能搞定
这个方法的流程
可以说是非常直观
第一步
先确认大方向是往上的
OK
第二步
耐心
等价格真的突破一个很关键的压力区第三步这一步最重要 也最需要耐心就是等价格回彩回来测试刚刚那个被突破的天花板看它是不是真的变成了地板
最后
当K线图上出现了一个确认的讯号
比方说出现一根很漂亮的看涨K棒
那就进场
如果你相信价格本身就说明了一切
喜欢干净的图表
那这个经典策略绝对是你的菜
好的
到目前为止
我们已经看完了三种风格
完全不同的策略
现在呢
我们把它们全部放在一起
来帮你做个总整理
看看哪一个才最符合你的交易性格
好
你看这张比较表
是不是一目了然
你可以问问自己
你是哪一种类型的交易者
如果你是个系统控
喜欢按部就班
照着SOP来
那建筑师策略
你一定要好好研究
如果你是那种直觉型的选手
总觉得自己能感觉到市场的下一步
那恋人策略你肯定要试试看
那如果你是个纯粹主义者
就爱简单干净
相信价格就是王道
那极简主义者的策略就是为你设计的
记住哦
最好的策略绝对不是那个看起来最复杂的
而是那个跟你自己看市场的方式
最能产生共鸣的
在我们结束之前
还有最后也是最重要的部分
不管你最后选了哪一个策略
有两个原则
是超越所有策略之上的金科玉律
你一定要牢牢记在心里
第一点
严格的风险管理
永远永远都要设定停顺
这是在保护你的本金
你才有明天继续交易的机会
绝对绝对不要让任何一笔交易
造成你无法承受的伤害
第二点
持续学习与复盘
你要定期去回顾你做的每一笔交易
不管是赚钱的还是赔钱的都要去分析
为什么因为市场一直在变
你当然也要跟着进化啊
说实在的这两点是所有成功交易者共同的DNA
好了今天我们已经把整个框架都给你了
三种强大的策略还有成功的核心原则
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目